on va passer maintenant à la guerre dans
la famille royale d'angleterre la guerre
carrément la presse a révélé des
tensions entre kate middleton et mégane
depuis le mariage avec harry les
polémiques elle ne cesse de continuer ça
évidemment la presse est ravi de tout ça
imaginez bien il ya une source proche de
la famille royale qui a raconté une
anecdote sur kate middleton
alors elle aurait fondu en larmes lors
des essayages de la robe de deux joyaux
d'honneur de sa fille mais charlotte
avant le mariage une mégane et harry en
mai dernier
donc là ça le torchon brûle et henry
williams se seraient disputés au sujet
de mégane après ça se dispute dans tous
les sens c'est dallas à buckingham
palace
regardons vous a fait un petit récap
décidément ça chauffe dans la famille
royale on le sait depuis quelques
semaines entre meghan markle harry et le
reste de la famille les relations
semblent s'être grandement dégradé il ya
quelques jours on apprenait que le
couple avait l'intention de s'éloigner
de la cour royale et plus précisément de
kate et william puisse qu'il cherchait
un appartement pour quitter leur
résidence officielle du palais de
kensington
selon des sources proches du dossier qui
se sont confié au telegraph la brouille
entre les deux femmes seraient allés
jusqu'à ce que kate s'effondre en larmes
tout commence quelques heures avant le
mariage de meghan markle en mai dernier
alors qu'il se trouve en présence de
kate et sa fille la princesse charlotte
demoiselle d'honneur pour l'occasion
l'essayage d'europe pour la jeune fille
aurait viré au drame
les deux femmes se seraient alors
écharpés et selon un proche de la
famille
la mariée n'y est pas pour rien dans
cette brouille mégane peut être
difficile
elle a de grandes exigences et continue
de se comporter comme une star
hollywoodienne en novembre lors de
plusieurs événements publics les deux
femmes s'étaient montrés
particulièrement distante ce qui semble
aller dans le sens de cette brouille
familiale dont tout l'angleterre parle
[Applaudissements]
les gones peut-être difficile
bon alors ça nourrit évidemment la
presse et qui sera avec qui ce qui se
réjouit de ça parce que évidemment on le
public est friand surtout là-bas en
angleterre et achète achète achète vous
y croyez vous n'y croyez pas est-ce que
d'abord la famille royale vous intéresse
elsa j'ai regardé le mariage que oui
vous étiez quand même devant leur télé
oui je choisis franchement le côté conte
de fées à moi j'adore ça
d'accord très romantique est ce que vous
croyez à ça leur d'abord il ya il ya de
brouille un différend reste un iliad et
les brouilles entre les filles mégane et
kate et la brouille entre les garçons
parce que le frère diallo tout et tu
l'as pas bien accueilli sap a été le
tapis rouge mais il faut savoir que
megan elle n'est pas évidente comme
comme vous la connaissez personnes tuées
n'était pas évidente
il était venu trois démissions dans son
cercle proche de personne sauf à
renoncer bonjean peu plus d'elle au
palais il l'appelle tous la tornade
parce que visiblement elle est très très
exigeante un train du four et à côté de
ça il ya kate qui la pauvre se tâte
doublé toutes les sorties chiant donc je
pense que lorsque j'allais gaz qui les
montent en épingle
c'était rolling stones des beatles parce
que ça fait vendre et qu'on dit bah
c'est une américaine donc on va dire
qu'elle est difficile et qu'elle est un
peu machin et que et l'autre elle est
plutôt sage et en plus comme l a amené à
monter sur le trône je ne sais pas oui
bien sûr c'est évident pour eux c'est du
pin merci beaucoup
vous avez raison non mais c'est du pain
bénit ces histoires moi j'y crois pas du
tout ce que je crois c'est
qu'effectivement mégane est mal perçu
encore par les anglais parce qu'ils sont
extrêmement conservateur ils ont tous
des mégane marqué l'histoire sombre et
sont belles je dis simplement que les
gays les anglais sont conservateurs et
que cette américaine qui débarque de
hollywood ça les agace quelque part
maintenant que la presse profite pour
raconter n'importe quoi on a l'habitude
comme un daniel les têtes couronnées ça
vous plaît ah j'adore j'adore bricoler
je travaille avec stéphane bern n'est
pas pour rien mais non mais mais
évidemment ça ça fait plus à l'est on a
envie que ça se dispute un petit peu
parce que c'est un petit peu trop sage
cette image moi la chose à laquelle je
ne crois absolument pas c'est une
brouille possible entre les deux frères
parce qu'ils ont vécu trop de choses
ensemble ils sont trop proches et je
pense que ce sont pas des petites
querelles de filles qui vont
qui vont gâcher tout ça franchement ça
j'y crois pas et puis on veut les
opposer mais en fait les enjeux sont
tellement différents megan elle n'aimait
pas du tout appelé à régner quête oui
donc en fait je pense que c'est voilà
tout ça est monté en épingle
s'ils déménagent parce que c'est ça qui
a mis le feu aux poudres oui le
déménagement
en fait elle n'avait pas envie mégane de
vivre dans l'ancienne garçonnière de
harry parce que c'était la garçonnière
de harry elle n'avait pas envie comme ça
qui est tous ces fantômes du passé je
pense que c'est comme ça et puis il y
avait pas assez de place
et puis ils vont avoir un enfant ils
veulent élever effacées selon ce qu'ont
fait qu était ressorti que je pense
qu'on part d'un fait réel mais on donne
des explications magali et après ils
sont pas du tout partie les salariés se
sont pas enfuis
c'est pas vrai du tout je me suis
renseigné en fait ça tape l'équipe à
redon de tpm people qui est notre cher
guillaume d'accord qui connaît très bien
le dossier et qui m'a expliqué sa donc
en fait l'équipe
effectivement acquis fin ils ont quitté
l'équipe de harry tout simplement parce
que l'avenir mais en fait il s'éloigne
tout simplement ce que l'équipe ne peut
pas gérer maintenant les enfants ils ont
tous des enfants elle est enceinte etc
il y aura trop de monde à gérer ils ont
des des choses qu'ils aiment de
différent tu m'a perturbé excusons donc
souvent ils ne se séparent pas il
s'entend très bien il ya aucun problème
merci mag est malade
[Applaudissements]